let's get to my next question here next
question is from Greg Greg said hey
David love your show I've got a baseball
question for you that I've never heard
anyone addressed before I'd love to hear
your thoughts on it every couple of
years there's a debate about the
prospect of using an asterisk in the
record books about one record or another
the first one I remember hearing about
was for Roger Maris breaking babe ruth
the single-season home run record Babe
Ruth did it in a shorter season Roger
Maris played more games therefore
shouldn't there be an asterisk I've also
heard a proposed during the steroid era
the strike-shortened seasons and other
reasons I can't recall but I've never
heard it mentioned about records set
before 1947 when baseball was segregated
why is there no talk about that in the
baseball community why for example isn't
there an asterisk next to Joe DiMaggio's
56-game hitting streak in 1941 there
were some excellent pitchers in the
Negro Leagues back then who potentially
would have prevented Joe DiMaggio from
having a 56 game hitting streak uh that
that this is really tough for me you
know and this applies to more than just
baseball rules change a good example is
in football the kickoff line in football
was recently moved such that now there
are way more touchbacks recorded during
kickoffs and touchbacks are a statistic
that is kept for kickers so should there
not be an asterisk now next to everybody
who sets a record for the number of
touchbacks because you're kicking from
way closer to the opposing teams end
zone now the counter to this would be
and Pat a lot of people have emailed me
about this kick-off thing interestingly
enough and and it was before you were
here so whenever I mention this people
email me and they go but David the
touchback record who cares about it it's
just not a relevant record a hitting
streak or Barry Bonds home run record in
baseball these are sort of more
important parts of the fabric of
baseball hitting streaks and home run
records are really important things that
seems to me sort of like a matter of
degree right I mean either the rules
have changed and there should be an
asterisk the rules have changed and
say we don't care about asterisks but to
pick and choose well you know uh we're
going to put an asterisk for home runs
but not for the hitting streak or
whatever I don't know I don't have a
strong feeling about this because in
every sport the rules do change over
time they absolutely do and you can't
just have a whole bunch of different
aspects maybe one star for right one
rule change to for another will change
yeah it is interesting in football uh
maybe people don't care about the
touchback rule but last year they moved
the extra point line that's why arts
back yep so Stephen Gostkowski is going
to for all time have the record of
consecutive extra points made right he
and in fascinatingly enough I believe
Stephen Gostkowski the Patriots uh
kicker he missed the point after last
year didn't he it was a crucial moment
yet was in a playoff game that ended up
costing the season that's right and that
you could argue if it was from the two
yard line instead of 12 I believe it got
moved or or something like that maybe
gostkowski would not have missed that
and the entire uh uh result of that game
would have been different I believe that
if you are going above and beyond the
rules of the game which I would consider
steroids to be outside of the rules it's
more appropriate to have an asterisk the
example of well listen there were really
good pictures in a different league and
the league was segregated that's not
measurable right Joe DiMaggio didn't
break any rule it was that he was
playing in a league that at the time did
not allow black pitchers that's
absolutely true but it's much harder to
measure the absence of something someone
setting a record for home runs and we
know they were on banned substances
that's a much more tangible thing that I
would put an asterisk next to that
that's my feeling on it yeah i agree
with you there and i think there's a
does the whole concept in sports to
where it's supposed to be a meritocracy
ya know it's just people in the field
and if you add store steroids into that
equation i mean it really kind of
muddies the water no doubt and you know
some people will say to me David this is
a nanny state we're telling players
whether they can use steroids or not
that's not for us to say uh we should
just allow all substances
to be used hey if those are the rules
then by all means we would all know hey
these guys are on steroids the steroids
are allowed if the rules are no steroids
then those are the rules that we should
be abiding by and that's that sort of
really my concern if you want to come to
me and say you know what we don't care
about the health of the athletes we
don't care about kids wanting to use
steroids because they're seeing so uh
clearly and obviously and openly that
their heroes their role models are using
steroids you want to take that risk go
and do it but for me it's but it's a
matter of the the rules as decided on by
the league some asterisks warranted some
I just don't see it